[Musique]
qui voyez vous lorsque vous me regardez
une personne handicapée est d'accord
mais quoi d'autre
à quoi pouvait vous pensez un jeune
homme qui paie une métisse qui l'a fait
un jeune qui a besoin d'être en
permanence un jeune sans avenir
je n'ai pas toujours été cloué dans son
fauteuil
c'est à l'âge de 19 ans que j'ai eu mon
accident de rugby et paradoxalement
c'est à partir de ce moment là que je
n'ai cessé d'aller plus loin et de
sortir de ma zone de confort je
n'oublierai jamais la tête de mon
médecin
après mon opération et encore moins de
la première phrase qu'il m'a dit vous ne
marcherez plus jamais de quoi me parle
et il
j'étais un sportif de haut niveau db sur
gens vivaient tous les jours je refusé
d'entendre la vérité
de plus il me parlait du handicap du
fauteuil roulant
j'avais aucun souvenir d'avoir vu une
personne en fauteuil roulant avant mon
accident ni même d'ailleurs de savoir
comment ces gens là pouvaient vivre
j'étais dans une phase de déni total
puis j'ai compris j'ai réalisé et j'ai
explosé
pourquoi pourquoi moi je pense que mes
parents se souviennent encore de ces
quelques mots qui résonnait dans ma
chambre de réanimation
je suis longtemps rester habiter dans
cette phase de colère me laissant guider
dans une routine de malades sans
vraiment penser que je pouvais gagner
quelque chose et pourtant
un jour alors que j'étais
confortablement installé dans ma
nouvelle vie l'idée les un jeune homme
rentre dans ma chambre d'hôpital on
avait sensiblement le même âge le même
parcours le même accident
sauf que lui il était en fauteuil
j'ai compris qu'à ce moment-là ça
voulait dire que moi aussi je pouvais
être en fauteuil et sortir de ses quatre
murs qui rythmaient mon quotidien sortir
de mon lit c'était sortir de ma zone de
confort dans laquelle je m'étais
finalement confortablement installés et
commencer ma reconstruction
la reconstruction est passé par un
objectif important voire même irréel
dans le monde du handicap
un objectif que j'avais atteint tout
naturellement avant mon accident mais
qui m'était devenu beaucoup plus
compliqué l'autonomie j'ai des souvenirs
très marquant dans l'atteinte de mon
objectif est notamment la première fois
où j'ai réussi à manger tout seul je
réceptionne est mon plateau dans ma
chambre d'hôpital et l'aide soignante
qui devait m'aider à partager ce repas
tarder un peu j'ai donc pris
l'initiative de commencer sans elle et
j'ai notamment ce petit souvenir de ce
petit fromage soigneusement emballé dans
du papier
j'ai réussi à manger la moitié du
fromage
l'autre moitié était sur mon nez mais
difficile au début lorsque vous avez des
moufles à la place des mains et peu
importe
c'était un moment magique j'ai également
se souvenir de la première bouche que
j'ai réussi à prendre tout seul avec la
bonne odeur de lessive de maman sur les
serviettes de bain tous ces petits
instants
toutes ces petites victoires m'ont
permis de poser des pierres et ainsi de
construire mon mur dans l'atteinte de
nos objectifs
l'autonomie tout cette petite victoire -
également permis de générer de la
confiance en moi et ça aussi c'était
quelque chose de nouveau chez moi avant
mon accident
j'étais souvent n'en doute pas sûr de
moi aujourd'hui j'ose j'entreprends et
je me donne à fond
me voilà donc autonome en fauteuil
roulant c'est déjà pas si mal mais un
objectif en cachant toujours un autre
j'ai ressenti le besoin de me relancer
dans une nouvelle carrière sportive de
haut niveau lors la de séjour dans un
centre de rééducation en bretagne j'ai
découvert une discipline qui
correspondait totalement à mes attentes
le rugby fauteuil le rugby fauteuil est
un sport paralympique qui se joue à
quatre contre quatre sur un terrain de
basket avec des fauteuils de type mad
max qui nous permettent de nous rentrer
dedans c'est un sport assez
spectaculaire par le dynamisme des chocs
entre les fauteuils
comme vous pourrez voir sur la vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est déjà de notre appétit qui peut
rien nous arriver de plus ce sport
ce sport véhicule également des valeurs
d'esprit l'équipe de combativité et de
respect j'ai trouvé dans cette
discipline
un épanouissement sportif mais pas que
la troisième mi-temps existe aussi au
rugby fauteuil et ça je peux vous dire
que c'est un excellent vecteur de lien
humain de rencontres avec d'autres
athlètes est l'occasion parfaite de se
relancer dans une nouvelle vie sociale
par contre sans club et sans argent pour
acheter l'ensemble des fauteuils à 6000
euros
difficile de pratiquer j'ai appris par
le passé à ne pas rester dans mon lit
j'ai donc monté un club trouver les
fonds et acheter les fauteuils depuis 9
ans j'ai eu la chance de participer à
deux jeux paralympiques
mais pas seulement le rugby fauteuil a
été également l'élément déclencheur d'un
nouveau projet et si j'utilisais ce
sport comme vecteur de sensibilisation
au handicap
c'est un sport qui est facile à
pratiquer pour les personnes valides car
il a été conçu pour des personnes
tétraplégiques avec donc peu de
capacités motrices
de plus il permet de mettre en situation
des personnes non initiées des personnes
de 7 à 77 ans vous ce sport véhicule
également une image positive du handicap
comme le fait qu'une personne handicapée
n'est pas spécialement fragile
finalement cette discipline permet tout
simplement de démystifier la vision
misérabiliste du handicap et sans vie
sociale
j'ai donc monté une association est
notre premier public a été des
collégiens car on a estimé plus facile
d'éduquer des jeunes générations que de
rééduquer des personnes ayant un âge
avancé je parle pas du tout ce vous bien
sûr la première fois que je suis
intervenu dans une petite école de
village m'a marqué à vie je posais
simplement des questions sur mes
capacités ou incapacité à réaliser des
faits et gestes de la vie quotidienne et
notamment la possibilité ou non de
pouvoir conduire tout seul et de rentrer
dans mon véhicule
cette question qui peut paraître
insurmontable pour la plupart d'entre
nous ne l'était pas du tout pour eux eh
bien tu te mets à côté de son véhicule
puis de transfert avec la force de tes
bras sur le siège conducteur
tu démontes en fauteuil tu conduis avec
tes mains j'avais l'impression d'être
stupide et de leur poser des questions
complètement stupide une autre anecdote
sympa la plupart des fois où les jeunes
essayent le rugby fauteuil il me demande
dans quel club je pourrais masque à
l'année prochaine
je leur explique que c'est un sport qui
n'est pas ouvert aux valides pour des
questions de législation et de
différence de capacité
il trouve cela encore stupide
après avoir visité plusieurs écoles du
département j'ai ressenti à nouveau le
besoin d'aller plus loin
et s'il intervenait auprès d'un autre
public un public également en difficulté
mais différemment une population non pas
privé de jambes mais privée de liberté
les détenus handicapés et détenus n'ont
pas de similitudes au premier abord
et pourtant accidents de la vie perte de
quelque chose de précieux et surtout un
fort besoin de réinsertion sociale et
professionnelle
de plus ces deux publics représentent
une image négative dans notre société à
laquelle il est facile de s'identifier
qui ici n'a jamais pris le volant en
ayant bu quelques verres ci ne s'est
jamais mis en situation de danger même
inconsciemment cette situation peut nous
arriver et à n'importe quel moment
nos discussions auprès des détenus se
porte sur notre capacité d'adaptation et
de reconstruction suite à un échec après
une détention après une rééducation il
est peut-être deux fois plus difficile
de se réinsérer socialement et
professionnellement derrière mais c'est
loin d'être impossible
lors d'une visite dans un centre de
détention féminin je m'adressais à un
groupe de détenus et à la suite de mon
intervention l'une d'entre elle prit la
parole et me dit tu viens notre
rencontre
tu nous parles comme si de rien n'était
tu nous regardes dans les yeux je trouve
cela vraiment appréciable alors j'étais
complètement surpris de sa réaction et
je répondais que je me batte et moi même
tous les jours pour ne pas être jugé
comment pourrais-je la juger sur un
premier regard sans la connaître elle
m'a regardé ella a souri j'ai le
sentiment qu'à ce moment-là l'a compris
que nous vivions tous les deux une
certaine forme de réinsertion sociale
à cet instant j'ai réalisé que nos
interventions auprès des détenus leur
servir et de sources de motivation dans
leur réinsertion
après les enfants
après les détenus pourquoi ne pas
toucher le monde professionnel il a
fallu innover pour toucher ce milieu
j'ai donc inventer un module de
formation de cohésion d'équipé axés
autour du handicap et du rugby fauteuil
je dois dire que ce dernier défi était
loin d'être évident la première fois que
nous sommes contactés par une grande
entreprise l'a marqué à vie nous sommes
donc contacté par sept grandes
entreprises
pour animer une formation de cohésion
des équipes
mon contact me dit que les membres de
cette équipe sont tous des directeurs et
qui managent tous 9000 personnes
pouvez-vous vous en occuper écoutez dans
mon association je gère actuellement
trois personnes le capitanat en rugby
fauteuil me fais m'occuper d'une grosse
douzaine d'athlètes pourquoi pas c'est
une excellente occasion d'aller encore
plus loin
après cinq heures de travail en salle 3
heures de rugby fauteuil
cette journée fut une réussite et un
sacré soulagement
et dire que ma différence devenait une
richesse pour la cohésion des équipes
j'estime que toute différence est une
richesse qui nous permet de s'identifier
mais également d'apprendre de se
rencontrer et de partager avoir peur des
différences par méconnaissance est un
comportement humain mais alors c'est
différent vous empêcher de l'avancé
depuis que je suis différent
depuis que je suis en fauteuil roulant
je n'ai cessé d'aller plus loin je n'ai
cessé de sortir de ma zone de confort
car rien ne me paraît vraiment
impossible
de plus j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
une multitude de personnes différentes
avec ti par leur expérience par leur
différence j'ai réussi à aller au bout
de tous ces projets alors est-ce que je
suis un jeune sans avenir
un jeune bloqués dans mon lit je n'ai
pas évaluer la situation d'handicap et
comme une situation d'échec mais plus
comme une situation qui m'a permis de
sortir de ma zone de confort et d'aller
chercher des victoires inattendues mon
accident sur un terrain de rugby n'est
pas un échec
l'échec aurait été de rester sur ce
terrain et de ne pas décoller ma
réussite a été d'aller vers d'autres
terrains porté par de nouveaux projets
vers la construction de mon bonheur
aujourd'hui je suis à nouveau sorti de
ma zone de confort
je me suis mis en difficulté et je suis
content et heureux de l'avoir fait alors
n'attendez pas de vivre un échec
n'attendez surtout pas de vivre un
accident pour vous même sortir de votre
zone de confort merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]